so initially today I had planned on
uploading Batman the court of owls part
1 and just kind of going from there but
I think one of the mistakes that we've
made with a lot of videos recently is
we've just kind of jumped into the
stories as opposed to doing the cover
for the stories the things that lead up
to making the stories make sense and
because the bad family is such a
prominent part of the night of Al's and
the end the story Batman in game death
of the family Batman eternal things like
that I think it's important to make the
bat family makes sense and to do
respective videos about each of the
characters before we actually jump into
this is so what we're going to do is
we're going to start here with Dick
Grayson quite possibly one of the most
popular characters to have ever existed
in the history of DC Comics and most
certainly one of the most well known if
that not the most well known version of
Robin in Batman's continuity
so Dick Grayson first appeared and
Detective Comics issue number 38 in 1940
and was really interesting here is that
he was created by the same guys who made
Batman he was made by Bob Kane and Bill
Finger then the question here was is it
possible to give a sidekick to Batman
that will bring in younger readers and
so this was the experiment that was
performed and initially this was
intended to be a one-off of sorts in the
sense that if it had failed the story
would have been self-contained to a
degree and they would have been able to
just kind of write Dick Grayson out of
the stories entirely but the exact
opposite happened Dick Grayson was a
resounding success for DC Comics and
what's really cool here is that between
Dick Grayson and Marvel's spider-man
we'll actually see this kind of
give-and-take where one will influence
the creation of the other and then the
creation of the other will influence the
other one and so we'll make this make
sense as we go along but with dick
Grayson's appearance this immediately
appealed to younger readers because
where Batman was cool and he was
mysterious and he was sort of dark to a
degree in this tone or I guess at least
as dark as you could be in the 1940s a
lot of younger kids were wanting someone
to relate to in comic books and the
status quo is we had established in
previous videos before our discussion
about spider-man or during our
discussion about spider-man comic books
were relegated to adults there were
really no teenagers here and so with
Dick Grayson stepping into the role of
being a sidekick for Batman what has
told a lot of teenage readers is that
teenagers are gaining respectability in
comic books
teenagers are becoming appealing in
comic books and so a lot of kids
immediately latched on to this idea and
Detective Comics number 48 or I'm sorry
number 38 when Dick Grayson was brought
in Dick Grayson was the child of a
trapeze group called the flying
Grayson's and over the course of the
story which was only written about 13
pages things were very very rushed and
so we quite literally jumped to one
portion of the story which tells us that
it's somewhere along the line the head
of Haley Circus was being I guess
extorted by a man named boss Zuko and
then once he refused to pay money to
boss Zuko boss Zuko had poured acid on
the trapeze ropes and it resulted and I
dig Grace's parents being killed and so
once the parents had died Batman had
appeared to de grâce and telling Dick
Grayson that he couldn't go to the cops
and tell them what had happened
and the reason why was because basu Co
pretty much owned the entire city then
some of Dick Grayson had gone to the
cops and told them then undoubtedly some
dirty cops would have ratted him out and
Dick Grayson would have been killed
within the day and so what Batman does
is he effectively takes Dick Grayson
under his wing and so again jumping back
to the 1940s here what we found was that
because of dick Grayson's success as a
sidekick as Robin in the Batman comics
in real time he stayed the sidekick of
Batman for almost 30 years which is an
unprecedented thing in comic books we
have yet to ever really see an instance
where by a major superhero we'll have a
sidekick
that will stay his sidekick for 30 years
now in this day and age and comic books
it's very rare that you have a really C
sidekick this is really kind of an
element that's long since been dead but
during this time period going from the
nineteen thirty I guess the 1940s into
the Silver Age when sidekicks began to
go away that this was an unprecedented
concept but what DC also recognized was
that due to the popularity of Dick
Grayson they had the opportunity to
expand him into other stories and so in
1964 following uh following the creation
I guess the implementation of Spiderman
DC had taken their brave in the bold
storylines of the brave of the bold line
with issue number fifty-four
and basically formed the Teen Titans now
because Spiderman was so successful
again Spiderman changed the mold by
saying that teenagers don't have to be
sidekicks teenagers can be the main
story here and so DC took this one step
further and said not only contain Agers
be the main story but teenagers can be
part of a teenage team they can be part
of a smaller team which is basically a
spin-off of the Justice League and again
this was a resounding success
now with the Teen Titans initially being
formed here this wasn't necessarily I
guess the actual formation that is to
say this didn't go by the publication
the Teen Titans this was simply giving
us the basis behind how the Teen Titans
had formed and again with Bob Haney and
Charles Parris writing this story what
we found was that a villain had shown up
but had basically required the the
organization and the efforts of two
other sidekicks of superheroes Aqualad
who was the sidekick of Aquaman and Kid
Flash who was the sidekick of the flash
and between these two individuals
coupled with with with dick Dick Grayson
what we found was that again this really
hit a tone with a lot of car a lot of
comics teenage fans they immediately saw
the opportunity for circumstance to
arise where they had their own team
publication now what we found was that
around 1970 or so that Neal Adams and
Danny O'Neil had basically taken over
the role of writing for Batman than
their goal here with the Silver Age
giving us a more dark kind of
connotation with superheroes and stories
was they were trying to reflect this
with Batman
and so what they did is they made Batman
a darker character but they also cast
aside Robin now this is again a major
thing in the history of dick Grayson's
continuity because after having been
together for almost 30 years this was a
shock we had seen this relationship form
between Bruce Wayne and Dick Grayson
where there were more father and son
than anything else and so as a result
fans were immediately stunned by this
but the question that DC had going
forward was is it possible to present a
circumstance whereby Dick Grayson can
stand on his own two feet is it possible
that he can simply have his own
publication is the popularity there and
so what we found was that in the back of
Batman comics we ultimately saw Robin
all right yes Dick Grayson getting his
own publication as backup features that
is to say he was stored in the back now
the way that DC had done this by virtue
of getting rid of Robin was a really
interesting thing initially he was just
kind of thrown in there we just kind of
I guess just turned the pages one day or
went out bought the comic one day and
Robin wasn't there it wasn't until 1987
when we learned why it was that Robin
had been removed in the first place and
what we found was that this story
appeared in Batman issue number 408 and
what this does is serve two purposes the
first thing is that of course again it
gives us the reason why Batman and I
Dick Grayson had split up but it also
gave us the origin of Tim Drake I'm
sorry of Jason Todd going into the going
into his publications or I guess several
years after his introduction and the
Batman stories and what this comic tells
us is that when Batman and Dick Grayson
were fighting together that is somewhere
along the line they had encountered the
Joker and the Joker had shot
de Grayson in the shoulder and as a
result because of this very parental
relationship that Batman and and Dick
Grayson had Batman didn't want to see
Dick Grayson subjected to a circumstance
whereby he could possibly die and so as
a result he had basically kicked Dick
Grayson out of the role of being Robin
and this tied into Robin getting his own
backup feature now with Robin being
stored in the back of the Batman comics
basically getting backup features this
proved to be successful albeit not
necessarily as successful as the Batman
stories what we eventually found was
that again DC was continuing to look at
the idea of Dick Grayson and so with
Dick Grayson sales still remaining
credited pretty steadily with Batman
still a Batman sales still remaining
relatively popular albeit very difficult
to differentiate between whether or not
these were popular because of Dick
Grayson still being in the stories were
simply just based on Batman DC began to
ask the idea again is it possible that
Robin can get his own solo feature
outside of the Batman publications can
we launch a series of stories with just
with just Dick Grayson and so what we
found was they did this in a couple
stages it was a gradual introduction to
us again building on the popularity of
the Teen Titans what we had seen was
that in 1980 DC came along with DC
Comics presents issue number 26 and what
this did was give us the new Teen Titans
this was more or less a reintroduction
of Dick Grayson back into the role of
being the leader of the Teen Titans and
this was a massively successful thing in
fact this would run for about about 16
years with the introduction of new Teen
Titans issue number one it ran from
about 1980 to about 1996 and a lot of DC
fans love this because it hit them in a
couple different ways for those who were
just now getting into DC Comics those
that were getting into DC in the 1980s
those who are getting into DC Comics
following the crisis on Infinite Earths
and those who were getting in in the 90s
could read this version of Dick Grayson
but they could also go back and look at
a lot of the previous stories of Dick
Grayson he again continued to resonate
with a lot of different people in
addition to the other individuals that
we saw that were introduced with the new
Teen Titans but what we also found was
that in 1980
for D CBN to continue capitalizing on a
success of Dick Grayson by introducing a
change in his character
what DC did is they introduced a story
line called the Judas contract story
line and this was a story whereby a
death stroke had basically gotten with a
woman named Tara Markoff and Tara
Markoff was is a little difficult to
explain here but she was effectively a
15 year old girl who had been previously
cast out of her society but had used her
ability to manipulate tectonic plates
for her own purposes to basically become
an assassin for hire and what was really
controversial here was that Deathstroke
actually ended up having a sexual affair
with this fifteen-year-old girl which
was something that was shunned by not
just only comic book fans but those in
the general media as something that just
really didn't need to be seen here but
as a result when she had taken on I
guess as a partner for Deathstroke she
had infiltrated the Teen Titans and an
infiltrating the Teen Titans the goal
was to effectively destroy the Teen
Titans from the inside out but
ultimately this had really began to go
awry she ended up killing herself in the
process but with issue number 44 Marvel
used this to introduce Nightwing now the
way the Nightwing's origin is given to
us has given to us in a couple different
ways and so what we're actually going to
do here is we're going to reference the
secret origins of Nightwing because for
me I think this is probably the easiest
history to follow then what we had found
was that shortly after after Dick
Grayson had been cast off from Batman he
had gone to visit Superman and the
reason why he had gone to visit Superman
was because in a lot of ways he had seen
Superman as somebody he could identify
with in the sense that they felt alone
they had no family there was really no
one they could go to because remember
for the longest time all Dick Grayson
had was Bruce Wayne his actual family
had been killed off and so as they began
to speak with a Superman Superman told
him of a story of a man on Krypton that
this person had been cast out of his
family in the same way that I did
Grayson had been cast out of a Batman
shadow that this person had gone on to
effectively become a superhero on that
planet and that well no one knew what
his actual name was that he went by the
name Nightwing and this immediately
resonated with Dick Grayson and so what
Marvel I'm sorry what DC did is they
came along and they basically began to
introduce
a series of publications with Dick
Grayson operating under the form of
Nightwing and this was such a resounding
success for Dick Grayson that DC would
actually never look back we would never
see Dick Grayson undertake the role of
Robin again
the only exception of him leaving the
Nightwing position was in 1994 at the
fall of the night falls story arc then
again as most of us know what the
nightfall story arc this was a
publication whereby Batman had had his
back broken by Bane and so as a result
he could not undertake the mantle of
Batman any longer and instead pass this
on to Dick Grayson now while a lot of
comic fans love the idea of Dick Grayson
playing Batman by this point
Nightwing was such a popular character
that DC really felt he had no choice but
to bring Bruce Wayne back and to put
Grayson back in the position of
Nightwing and again this came in two
different ways one Bruce Wayne was
Batman there was really no way to get
around that there was really no altering
that there really wasn't a circumstance
whereby Batman fans or DC fans as a
whole or even pop media outside of DC
Comics would really buy into the idea
that Bruce Wayne wasn't going to be
Batman anymore but again because of the
popularity of Nightwing they had to go
back to their respective roles and so
what this does is this leads us into the
new 52
now with the new 52 what DC did here is
they went back and they basically
consolidated all of the origins of Dick
Grayson and they brought it to us in a
pretty simple and elegant way in the
secret origin stories but they do this
in two parts the first half covers the
beginnings of Dick Grayson and the
second half covers pretty much him
becoming Nightwing and everything after
Nightwing but again these are very short
and to the point they're not designed to
be very lengthy and drawn-out concepts
but picking up with secret origins issue
number one what we find here is that DC
is basically going with this five year
window continuing this five year window
with the character Dick Grayson and what
I mean by this is that for the guys who
were unaware with the new 52 what DC had
come back and done was basically said
that characters like Batman Superman
Wonder Woman that they have 0 years
these are the points at which Clark Kent
begins to step into the role of becoming
Superman this is when Bruce Wayne steps
into the role of becoming Batman when
dianna becomes Wonder Woman this is how
they begin to step into that role so
that when we're first introduced to
these characters with issue number one
so to speak that a five year window has
basically passed here and so with the
secret origins of Dick Grayson what we
find is that we pick up with the very
beginnings at its estate Dick Grayson as
he's part of the flying Grayson's then
again much like the original origin we
had found that a man named Tony Zucco
was attempting to extort protection
money from the owner of Halley's Circus
but when the owner of Haley Circus
refused to give in the result was that
Tony Zucco had his henchmen I guess
damaged the wire of the flying Grayson's
and so the parents of Dick Grayson had
fallen to their deaths which had of
course resulted in the owner of Haley
Circus giving in but what DC also does
here is they begin to paint a more
intricate picture of Dick Grayson they
begin to give us this information of
just how much did Grayson and Batman
have in common which was a great concept
when it came to bringing in new readers
what they told us here was that once
Dick Grayson had become aware of the
fact that his parents were more or less
murdered that what he had been doing was
sneaking out at night he had been going
about the process of trying to find Tony
Zucco trying to find I guess has worked
his way up the ladder until he could
eventually locate Tony Zucco and
presumably kill him
now once Batman had realized what it was
a Dick Grayson was doing he had revealed
his identity as Batman to Dick Grayson
but he had also taken Dick Grayson under
his wing and again tying into the
intricacy of this what they do or what
DC does is they show us that day Grayson
what do this very rigorous training
process much like we get seen in the
initial origin this is really more I
guess a explain more in-depth here in
the sense that he's taught how to use
his acrobatic skills in a way to where
he can incorporate stealth and guile to
effectively become just as capable as
Batman is now the second part of this
this origin story I guess comes in
secret origins issue number eight and
what this does is it basically picks up
where or I guess for secret origins
issue number one left off but the issue
here is that DC runs through this pretty
fast in fact they cover pretty much all
of it over the course of two pages what
they basically tell us is that again the
idea of the Teen Titans things like that
is it all taken place during this five
year window that once Dick Grayson it
under under way
role of being Robin that the time
eventually came when he wanted to leave
the role of Robin when he wanted to
escape the role of Robin he of course
was for the most part removed this
position by a Batman but this has been
something that had been along and coming
with his character the result was that
over time he adopted the role of
Nightwing but then as he played the role
of Nightwing for a while alongside the
Teen Titans he even abandoned that role
and this is where things begin to change
this is where DC basically picks up with
the new 52 by saying that once that Dick
Grayson had abandoned the role of
Nightwing he'd basically become this
sort of a contract person in the sense
that he had underwent the name were
under with the change of calling himself
Grayson and become to a degree a kind of
Hero for Hire so to speak but ultimately
this leads us into the current run of
Grayson and this leads us into the
current run where we stand with
declaration de grâce and in relation to
Batman and the Batman family so again
we're going to go ahead and cut this
video here because if we go any further
we'll actually end up impeding into the
roles that he's been in in terms of I
guess Knight of the Owls and Batman
eternal and Batman in game and of course
that's something we don't want to do
quite yet with that being said I'm going
to go ahead a video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys on it please
be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the evidence
from comics explained and talk to me
directly